at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking question medic organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton this
episode is brought to you by Vimeo Pro
which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a
bunch of my startups already use Vimeo
Pro including wealthfront who uses it to
explain how wealthfront works TaskRabbit
uses it to tell their company's story
and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers
Airbnb Etsy etc why do they use it well
Vimeo Pro provides enterprise level
video hosting for a fraction of the
usual cost features include gorgeous
high quality playback with no ads up to
20 gigabytes of video storage every week
unlimited plays and views and a fully
customizable video player which can
include your logo custom outro etc you
also get VIP support and you get all of
this for just $1.99 per year that's $17
a month with no complicated bandwidth
calculations or hidden fees and you can
try it risk-free for 30 days so check it
out Vimeo comm forward slash business
that's VI m EO com forward slash
business and use promo code Tim to get
25% off that's a special discount just
for you guys so check it out Vimeo com
forward slash business promo code tip
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on the show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that
I've invested a significant amount of my
own money at least for me in the team
and the company itself so I am an
investor and hope to soon use it as a
client now back to the recommendation as
a Tim Ferriss show listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
now I do have to read a mandatory
disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there is the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealth front comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it they've become
massively popular just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
Tim BJ welcome to the show thanks for
having me here it's very cool yeah I
appreciate it and we are sitting in
Venice at my friend's house Devin and
his his friend Travis Brewer who's on
American Ninja Warrior so we have this
incredible workout facility to the right
to my right I guess in the garage but
you do not you work in Venice but you
live an hour away I live over an hour
away so I've been getting into podcasts
I actually enjoy I was telling you on
the way and I enjoyed getting to see
this other part of town because la is
really like several different cities and
I've never really known the west side so
it's worth it to me at least for now to
spend that hour and and listening to
podcasts on the drive it's really like
an extra hour of reading a day do you
have any any particular go-to podcasts
the moment I just started getting into
yours
what else do I like I love this podcast
called the great debates comedy enough
comedy debate podcasts people really at
the top of their intelligence to Harvard
and friends of mine who are you know
very well-educated erudite comedy
writers just going at the most trivial
and and that's bizarre topics one topic
was it would be cool if the Pope had
enough
fair with maura Tierney and one of them
took the side the Catholic Church needs
this sort of you know jolt and
rebranding and the other person saying
what's the point of an institution like
this you know so so it's like debate
club I mean it's yeah and then there's
one intelligence squared which is sort
of like the serious debate the serious
version of it yeah the serious version
of the comedy version of the serious
thing and that was that's been really
interesting too for those of you
wondering what the whining is it's not
it's not BJ that's that's Molly my dog I
you mentioned to Harvard friends or
fellow Harvard graduates I have a
question about Harvard and and you're a
Princeton I went to the lesser-known
with P but uh it seems like there is a
rich history of people coming to
Hollywood from Harvard that you don't
associate with say Yale or maybe maybe
so but I haven't I haven't come across
it as much or other Ivy's why is that
because it seems to go back quite a ways
I mean am i my family at one point new
Henry beard who then oh yeah helped
create National Lampoon yeah and it just
seems to go way way back and I'd love to
hear why that is I really don't know the
main correlation that I am familiar with
is the Harvard Lampoon which is a really
one-of-a-kind comedy magazine that has
its own spectacular Castle building in
the middle of prime real estate in
Harvard Square William Randolph Hearst
funded this this incredibly bizarre and
exciting old building and that has
fostered a lot of intelligent people
trying to get into this building slash
magazine slash party house and those
people sort of train each other really I
wouldn't quite say viciously but but
really rigorously about comedy this joke
doesn't progress this joke is
predictable and it's very rare that you
will get 19 year olds being hard on
funny 18 year olds year after year and
so I think that is a training system
that is unlike just about anything else
you'd be exposed to at that age so that
has led to a lot of people falling in
love with and becoming very good at
comedy writing which is you know real a
building block of entertainment that can
be put to you so a lot of people have
traditionally graduated the Harvard
Lampoon and gone on to write for The
Simpsons or Senate live or many many
other shows and I think once you see
graduates do that you kind of think oh
maybe I could do that a big advantage I
think of going to a fancy school or my
dad who did not go to a fancy school but
is a writer a lot of people ask me oh
did you have those advantages yes of
course
to an extent but I find the biggest
advantage is just not thinking that it's
a crazy idea to try to be a comedy
writer or to try to be a writer
many people waste years working as a
lawyer working you know whatever they do
that they think of as as a more
reasonable choice before they finally
get the courage to write so I think the
the huge advantage is if you have the
talent no matter where you are if you
believe that it's a reasonable choice of
action you're extremely fortunate and
that that I think is a main advantage of
going to Harvard he doesn't seem crazy
right I mean you you have these these
historical case studies of people who
have done exactly what you might
fantasize about doing I what in the
rigor and the training is very
interesting to me because I was the
graphics editor at the the Princeton
tiger so the satire magazine cartoons
illustrations that was my department and
I wanted that job partially because Jim
Lee who's sort of iconic hero in the
comic book world for me had that
previous post at Princeton and I found a
bunch of his drawings actually they did
when he was shit-faced drunk after going
to a party on Nassau Street but that's
that's a separate story the the approach
really was do something funny and there
wasn't a lot of structure I mean there
was feedback if something sucked
obviously or just didn't get any type of
laughs whatsoever but where did that
structure develop I mean did pee
we'll come back from say industry and
help instill that in some way or did it
just develop organically among the
students the career path of it oh no I
mean the are getting hard on say
underclassmen and no and and looking at
whether something progresses or not yeah
well I imagine that was simply imitative
of other you know rigorous
extracurriculars at a school like that
where you know the ski club or you know
rowing or the Harvard Crimson newspaper
whatever probably it's more inherited
from that because a lot of people want
to do these activities and you limit it
to the people that you feel and it's an
incredibly subjective practice but are
the most talented at comedy writing and
so you put them through well can you do
this can you do that and you have to
write a number of pieces in order to get
on the staff so I think that you know
everything at a place like that is is
very competitive and and so this is just
that same rigor applied to this
incredibly subjective and often thought
to be trivial field of comedy writing
did you know this does not lead to the
best comedy writers by any means it is
just it's that's one advantage and the
other advantage is that they believe
they can do it there are also huge
disadvantages to coming from the Harvard
Lampoon which is a lack of sort of life
experience or being in touch with what
real people actually find funny or a
sense of cockiness that is very
antithetical to comedy so there's
definitely advantages and disadvantages
to coming from a place like that did you
at what point in your undergrad did you
get involved with the Lampoon well I
tried to get on from the very beginning
so I tried you comp is the term for you
know auditioning for it with your
writing so I tried three straight
semesters so I didn't get on until the
middle of my sophomore year but I wanted
to be on from day one what do you think
changed between your first attempts and
getting accepted how did you how did you
in forever was it just that I have no
idea I probably just improved because I
was older and had been doing it longer
but it's also
incredibly subjective if I had not
gotten on I had vowed to never try again
and beside those people didn't know what
the [ __ ] they were talking about and
then I do get on and actually I did keep
a healthy sense of this is not the
be-all end-all but it's so subjective
how does when you then did writing after
college well a little actually let's
let's not hit fast-forward to quickly
although I'm happy to jump around the
the next step after graduating what
happened in the year after graduation
well I have sort of bizarre sort of
course of events and what it has in
common with everyone else is that
everyone who gets a job in show business
they have a story that's not replicable
that's the one constant ironically so
what happened was I was one of my main
extracurriculars at Harvard was I put on
a show called the BJ show with another
kid named BJ who was like a campus
celebrity he was like a reality show
star before reality because he had
stowed away on a plane to visit his
family for Thanksgiving this is before
9/11 so it wasn't quite as bad or but
it's still you know it made the papers
Harvard students toes away to the on
plane he was the guy from the plane you
know and so I saw an opportunity here
you know to hitch my fame to his and we
put on the to get attached at the plane
guy attached to yeah it's like you know
I have the same name as the guy was in
the plane maybe we should do something
together so we put on the show and I got
you know so my comedy friends we wrote
this sort of it was a variety Sheila it
was a variety show and parody of a
variety show called the BJ show my
senior year I decided let's invite Bob
Saget to perform in the show because I
had heard that he was a really filthy
stand-up comic which he is know what was
the the timing on this this was probably
2001 2001 yeah okay so this is before
America's Funniest Home Videos after oh
I'm sorry after yeah so he's well known
as a
you know family friendly guy right but I
have heard rumors that he'll disability
so I think maybe we can book him maybe
we can maybe we can honor him at the
Harvard Lampoon and because he'll want
the award he'll come and do the show
which works perfectly I approached his
management I cold called his management
and said I'm calling from Harvard we
want to get Bob Saget an award and
feature him in the show
and the show you know the proceeds went
to charity wasn't a scam for me I just
thought it'd be a great show by the way
that's a great thing always if you don't
care about the money always give the
money to charity because then everyone
will do it and often you just don't care
about the money you just want to put on
something cool so that's the thing I
learned in college that I'll probably
use again if any time I have like some
cool scheme they're like sure keep them
like who cares so I cold called his
management I asked my dad how do you
think I get in touch with Bob Saget he
said call CIA
we're from like Boston I don't know how
he does he said look up call for one one
get CAS number and ask CIA they'll
probably know it's like that's so smart
so I'm one of those big agencies in town
yeah something I call CIA I say do you
guys represent Bob Saget the
receptionist says no I say do you know
who does they say I think Brillstein
gray so I look up Brillstein gray I call
Brillstein gray they do represent Bob
Saget they put me through to a guy I
explained my case he says send the send
the stuff you're writing for Bob I'll
take a look this guy later becomes my
manager so the manager Michael price
likes the material recommends that Bob
does it Bob comes out and does the show
which is a very highly scripted show
there's a parody of full house called
the lost episode of full house in which
Bob learns about sex from Uncle Jesse
very dirty very funny anyway so after
the show Bob and he had brought his
show's creator he was doing a new show
that never really went anywhere but it
lasted one season it was called raising
dad oddly it starred kat dennings and
brie Larson who are now both very very
successful as well but they hired me
they were like oh cool a young edgy
writer Harvard Lampoon perfect and they
gave me a job on that staff while I was
you know about to graduate so I'm
graduate
perfect setup perfect in a way you know
I mean too good to be true on a career
level but again like I didn't I really
had these fantasies of being a great
artist a great you know filmmaker and
you know a sort of a family WB show I
didn't want to move to LA I knew that I
shouldn't say no to this and I didn't
say no to it but it was uh you know I
actually wanted to be like a starving
artist you know I see I'm like look I'm
from like a suburb starving artist means
like borrow a little money and like live
cheap I have no real illusions but I
didn't I had mixed feelings so it was
sort of a dream come true in the sort of
career moving forward but it was you
know I was not what did you think you
what type of starving artist did you
think you wanted to be when you have
sophomore junior I had read this book
easy riders raging bulls about
independent film and had you recommend
it highly recommend it when you see
riders raging but easy riders raging
bulls about sort of filmmaking in the in
the glory days of the 70s and I wanted
to be like that and then there's a
sequel about sort of the Miramax like
the 90s Tarantino Kevin Smith that is
also good but I really I wanted to write
like a screenplay that would like blow
Hollywood apart it was so edgy and
innovative etc and then demand to direct
it and you know that's that's I think
anyone who saw Pulp Fiction as a
teenager that was their fantasy so that
was very much my fantasy and you know in
my privileged want to be artists mind
this was a sellout move but you know I I
knew I knew it would be even more like
privileged and like I Rowley to turn it
down I mean it's an interesting paradox
I've noticed this when I was young I
thought oh I'll never be a sellout if
anyone ever offers me something sell
Audi I'll always say no then you realize
there's a huge integrity pull towards
doing the sella thing because you think
Who am I to turn down all this money for
something that someone else's would you
know struggle their whole lives to at
cetera and you actually feel very guilty
into towards at least doing what you
would have considered a sellout thing so
that's it's an interesting paradox that
I've observed with a lot of successful
people they get you know they get
offered a really lame movie for a ton of
money and their thought isn't [ __ ] that
I'm an artist their thought is God Who
am I I'd put my kids through college
just to do a Christmas movie Who am I to
say no it's very surprising I mean it
makes sense but I I'm so it does make
sense but it's a it's a it's an
incentive of guilt as opposed to sort of
an incentive of you know focus in a way
it's kind of like the Christmas story or
it's like there are starving kids in
China you know and you're like okay I'll
eat this food that you couldn't find me
right how did you then make decisions or
what happened after you're offered that
gig on the I took it you took it you
know I took it I moved to LA started
writing for it and I you know I looked
around the room I I it's interesting I
kept telling myself I'm making so much
money because for a kid at that age it's
so much money but any job I've had since
then I made more money on the office for
example and I never thought I'm making
so much money so any time I'm telling
myself I'm making so much money making
so much money that's a warning sign that
you're doing the wrong thing so I would
tell myself that because I gradually
realized this isn't the life I want I'd
look around this writers room and think
these are not the jobs I want and I
really and I'm glad I did I really had
these dreams of doing something
important and visible and exciting and
the only people in the room who I did
aspire to be something like we're Bob
Saget who would come by now and then in
his fancy car and cool sunglasses and
tell ten jokes and leave and get to be
the star of the show and Jonathan Katz
who created the show and it previously
created dr. Katz on Comedy Central a
cool show oh yeah hello and he also came
by now and then gave some words of
wisdom and jokes and then left and was
also celebrated for his own voice and I
thought well those are the guys I want
to be and they were both stand-ups so I
I had never thought of doing stand-up
before then but I realized well how how
insurmountable is this being a stand-up
is writing a joke and then saying the
joke and that is what I'm doing in this
writers room I write a joke I say it out
loud to see if it goes in the script I
guess I I could try that and try to be
like them and so as the show was winding
down I signed up for open mics around LA
and I would start you know saying
one-liners into a microphone and I was
kind of doing stand-up comedy
what was the do you remember any of your
early bits when you yeah well the first
time was a real disaster and one of my
most important piece of advice to anyone
doing stand-up is if you're really gonna
try stand-up booked you're a whole week
of shows your whole first week in
advance
so you can't quit so you can't quit
because I got up all this courage due to
my first show it was at a youth hostel
the Hollywood youth hostel it was
October 10th 2001 so less than a month
after 9/11 all my jokes were about 9/11
and I was not a good comic and the crowd
didn't speak much English so and I
followed a guy who killed he did an
impression of Robert De Niro taking a
dump and I have to say it was great it
was a great impression and you didn't
need to know English and it was
completely opposite of what I was doing
and so I did this bit it was horrible
and that the host said after me to try
to you know keep the show going all he
could muster for me was takes a lot of
courage to get up on this stage after
that I did not get on stage for three
months I had to work up the courage all
over again because it had been such a
disaster in that time I was like you
know what Tuesday I'm going to this
coffee shop Wednesday I'm going to this
bar you know all these open mics and you
know the first night back I did pretty
well in the second night I didn't do
well but you can't make each night a
referendum on whether or not you should
be doing it you just have to do a bunch
and how did your approach change between
that first bomb and the second sort of
collection of attempts it was really it
was exactly that it was the idea that uh
that I'm gonna really do this night
after night and I will evolve the act
and you know I was really
bad for a while but you know let's say
you do 20 jokes and three of them get
pity laughs well those are the three
keep then after a while one of them
always does well well that's your opener
and now two of them do well well now
you'd have a closer and you sense okay
when I do this kind of joke it does well
and you know it evolves that way and
what did your parents do you mention
your dad wrote he also he wrote some
memoirs or ghost words yeah that's what
he was some big people yeah I mean what
are some simple the biggest one he did
it was Lee Iacocca had the biggest son
first one he did he also did the memoirs
of Nancy Reagan of Tip O'Neill
Magic Johnson which was very exciting
for me he worked with Tim Russert on two
books and George Stephanopoulos so a lot
of political people and on both sides of
the spectrum and a lot of just eclectic
business leaders you know various people
what did your what did your mom do my
mom is a teacher now she's done a bunch
of things though she's also kind of an
eclectic career what what did they think
of your move to start uh to that
startups that comes a little later
stand-up similar-sounding word what did
the how do they well yeah how they feel
about that one of the conversations like
yeah I think they thought I wasn't very
good you know there my dad also is the
co-editor of a couple humor books that
are very good the big book of Jewish
humor and the big book of new American
humor and my family like comedies a big
deal to us like we watch they watch
Seinfeld every night Seinfeld and key
and Peele are the only things my parents
watch which i think is very good taste
so you know I think they kind of just
they definitely supported me writing you
know I'd studied literature at Harvard
you know my dads are right or there was
nothing again huge advantage for me that
my parents thought writing was like a
good a solid job you know and then
stand-up was where they were like like
okay get it out of your system this is
not you but whatever you know they never
said this to me but in retrospect it's
like I it's the same thing on stage when
the audience is laughing and then you
stay something off the cuff and you get
a huge laugh and you realize oh they
weren't even laughing before my parents
were like supportive supportive
supportive and then they really
supported something different you're
like okay so you were not okay you're
just being polite fair enough
and the that was the sort of a we're
slow you know they they're supportive
people they came around and you know
they supported the office you know and
so when did the what happened between
that start up I really want to say start
up it's just well this is why I'm taking
a break from startups cuz I'm completely
brainwashed the you took a from that
that's first you have a high nose
interview from stand-up to start up I
could yeah I could be that could be your
memoir that could be should from that
point to the office what happened
between those from that point to the
office while raising dad got cancelled I
continued doing stand-up I ran out of
all the money that I had saved on my big
money year in about you know year and a
half two years of doing open mics and
you know gradually getting better to the
point where at the end of sort of after
a year and a half which is a long time
when you are a kid from the suburbs so
long them it's a long time but compared
to most stand-ups you know I got very
lucky of course but it did feel like a
very long time because I had been
working after about a year and a half I
got decent definitely decent a stand-up
and I was starting to get booked at
respected alternative rooms at The
Improv and you know there's a lot of
people in Hollywood that are always
looking for anyone half promising to
sign or to put on showcases and I was
becoming that comic that people would
say oh there's a new guys he's pretty
good you know that kind of guy and at
the end of that a bunch of things the
end of that sort of two-year stretch a
lot of things kind of happened at once I
got cast on the show Punk'd sure I
replaced at Shepherd is the new guy
which I thought that oh that's what I'll
be famous for for the rest of my life
I'm the guy from Punk'd so I like I did
pranks on Hilary Duff and usher and
people like that incredibly fun and I
got booked on Conan I got booked on
Comedy Central was the usher prank I
have a vague memory this is this one his
brother
was set up to steal jewelry and then I
tell him I'll sure handle that's so well
and great and then I tell uh sure you
know we can let this go if you record a
radio ad for our store and do this rap
that I wrote
they wrote a really funny grab and I
have to wrap this to usher so hard to
keep a straight face and one of the
brilliant touches the writers I put in
is that in the rap uh sure refers to
himself as ice and then I apologized
that we originally wrote this for
vanilla ice
who passed so I got to do really funny
cover things and around this time I was
on a showcase Stella a stand-up showcase
for a network and you know now I'd
booked Punk'd and stuff like that and
that's when Greg Daniels who's creating
the American office saw me and thought
he was already looking for people that
could write an act and my jokes were
very clearly like you know clever
writing they weren't like a raw
personality or anything so he thought oh
maybe you can do and I had had a writing
job maybe you could be a writer actor
which at the time was it was a very
experimental idea that was gonna ask you
why he was very for that because he had
worked at Saturday Night Live and he had
a good experience where there was a
small gang of people who were kind of
writing their own things and also the
British office had had been a small you
know Ricky Gervais had written so much
of it so he was totally right let's
let's not have a corporate feeling show
with the writing staff and a cast let's
cast kind of funny people who can kind
of do it as a little unit and what was
so what was the very beginning of the
office like for you um
the beginning of the office was very
exciting creatively especially because
it was not thought to be a show that
this is now I got to feel like that
starving artist like you know the actual
integrity this was not considered a
successful a show with any chance for
success it was a very drab there's no
laugh track there's no colors it's bleak
it's not a pretty cast its the jokes are
very slow and dry and it's a remake of a
British show
that you know NBC had a track record of
disastrous remakes so it was a six
episode midseason order you know it was
really actually no it was just a pilot
order and then we squeaked into six
episodes so the beginning was you know
but it was that the people working on it
were brilliant Steve Carell
improvisation Zand Greg Daniels sort of
joke pitches and story outlines and you
know pretty soon this very lean writing
staff of Mindy Kaling and Paul
Lieberstein who played Tobey on the show
and a bunch of other you know real Larry
Wilmore who now hosts um the nightly
show on Comedy Central
you know real real lean group and you
know so creatively was extremely
exciting and and then it was bizarre
when it became successful because we
held on to do Cavanaugh's as the show
that for the rest of our lives we'd meet
one or two comedy fans who are like
that's a classic you know that's what we
were going for if I like mr. show like
cult status and when did it when did you
feel the tipping point or was there a
particular event or moment yeah at a
time when you're like holy [ __ ] this
thing is actually yeah going to be
successful or ending of the second
season
it was around December I think so we've
been out for like over a year but only a
few episodes and they moved us from two
things happened they moved us from
Tuesday to Thursday which I felt was
very important because now you know the
night you're on doesn't matter so much
in the DVR era but back then I my theory
was that you wouldn't want to watch a
show about an office at the beginning of
your work week like a fair assumption
it's funny on Thursday it's almost so
far so there was that and then the big
thing was that the Apple iTunes store
process began and we because our our
cult audience was very young and tech
savvy they made us a very big hit on the
iTunes Store even though we were not a
hit on NBC and then people were walking
around with like video iPods with the
office on it and they were sending each
other you know links to download it and
stuff and so it was really one of the
first
chose to be a hit like an online hit in
that way and that really was this viral
you know proto viral way that the word
spread about the show and so I have to
ask a question that I've always wanted
to ask somebody involved with the office
because I have no idea how this came to
pass but a fan sent me a link to a clip
at one point the the 4-hour workweek
came up in an episode of the office
where there's this big debate going on
amongst everyone and someone says what
do you mean I sent you an email uh
pointing to Daryl and Daryl says I don't
check email till 12 - yep
very specific question in the room when
that was pitched I don't remember whose
it was
it was just I thank you for being part
of that joke III working backwards from
what we must have meant it was just
funny like every little thing that's
going wrong you know for Michael on this
episode it was really hilarious in made
I mean really made my week that was
awesome it was very very surprised to
come across it the the the office what
are some lessons learned through your
experience at the office what did you
get better at the end and why lessons
learned and we could talk about Simon
you could you could keep you you could
have a particular person in mind if that
helps
yeah well one lesson that I learned from
that as well as from stand-up was that
you really never know how something's
going to play until you test it scenes
that felt like they were just airtight
winner hilarious scenes in the writers
room sometimes just would not work on
set and you had to learn to not be angry
at it for not working you had to learn
to listen to the audience and that's a
major major lesson there's no one
smarter than the audience and it was so
this is actually a something that it was
filmed in front of a live audience
no but there's you know that's that's
where but occasionally you just feel it
if it's flat it's flirty to a table read
of each episode so you have a big room
of people laughing or not laughing and
then when you take it down if it's like
a rewrite scene or something
you know Steve Carell says it and you're
just there you know even just you and
the cameraman like you're smiling or
you're not right
our then you edit it and it works or
doesn't and that was I think a humbling
lesson for someone who thought of
himself as you know a real writer
because writing is really it's just a
guess and you know there's no there's no
penalty for doing your homework
so if you want to test your stand-up at
a thousand rooms before you do it on TV
or if you want to test the stuff you're
writing for the office in as many groups
as you can do it because you're not
you're not smarter than the audience
it's for the audience would you test
your material you work one for the
office and other environments in like
little rooms yeah everyone had their own
office so like you know Mindy and I
would like read scenes out loud and you
know just see if they sounded right you
either see someone smile or not yeah
yeah what about Steve Carell did you
observe anything particular oh well I
learned something from him which was one
time I you know wrote a bunch of jokes
because the scene wasn't working and I
was the guy in charge of you know
bringing alts as we call them you know
other versions so I bring alts to the to
the set and he looked at all of them and
he said I don't know these just feel
like jokes to me and I was like well
yeah they're jokes that's what I do
that's what we do but for him
comedy had to come from comedy as a
byproduct of authenticity I would
compare it to the difference between a
kid who knows he's cute and a kid who
doesn't a kid who knows he's cute is not
cute a kid who just says something
without realizing cuteness hilarious and
that's what he wanted the office to feel
like like these people don't even know
how funny they are so that was important
I'm sure I'll come with a lot more
lessons because I learned more on that
than we could let me if I could talk
about the writing process that I would
love for you to read yeah I'd look for
you to talk about that well the way that
we would start a season and
I've adapted this to many things I've
done since we'd start with what we would
call a blue sky period which was my
favorite part of every year for 2 3 4
weeks sometimes if we had a long time
every single day in the writers room was
just what if there's no penalty there's
no maybe we can't there's no but this
one conflicts with that one
what if Dwight goes to the moon what if
Jim and Pam get divorced what you know
just every idea is is valid for like for
a while that was just an amazing period
and then how long would that last that
would last if we didn't have much time
for it because we had different
pre-production schedules between two
weeks and four weeks that's a decent
stretch of time yeah and was there
structure to the what-ifs like was there
somebody on a white board taking but it
was sort of improvised day to day like
the showrunner would say you know all
right we don't have anything for Dwight
or like how about everyone split up and
come with ten ideas for Ryan or you know
let's come up with more ensemble stories
you know there would be sort of a
leadership that way it wasn't just all
sitting around but it's an assemble
story if you like I know what's really
words mean separately but the whole cast
is involved in one thing rather than I
say a story B story so that was
incredible those and it really was
creatively important and I tried to
replicate that in everything I do just
not shut down any ideas for a period
just generate it yeah
and then the best ideas will have there
will fuel you past the problems after a
few weeks of blue sky we would love some
ideas so much it would be obvious what
the best let's say we were gonna start
with six stories right
it was obvious what the best 15 or and
then we'd start talking more seriously
and then we'd look which ones do our
love for the story carry us through the
inevitable well how could Dwight be here
if he's also there and you know stuff
like that but finding the love first and
then letting that carry you through the
problem you split yeah you find what you
love about an episode or in other things
have done a story idea or a stand-up it
you know you've gotta just indulge
develop
what you love about it so that when you
then come up with but then we couldn't
show this on TV or it is kind of
contrived or whatever it is you'll
you'll love it so much that you will
have the inspiration to fix it
got it so you're developing the piece
that you've fallen in love with enough
so that you can handle all the
inevitable yeah fixer-upper issues I do
that with my other writing too I always
start with what I love and if I'm stuck
on a story and I approach it the next
day I never go to the hard part first
some writers probably do I go to them
what's my what's the one thing I'm proud
of in this story could you give an
example and not a thought my head about
the other like there might just be i
pathetic or a phrase or a beautiful line
that I'm proud of that I I'm just so
certain everyone's gonna think I'm
brilliant so I started that and I get
excited and then I want everything else
to live up to that rather than start at
the problem that's a personal thing I am
very motivated by positive thinking were
there any other an ego positive you go
you know use your own ego to fuel
yourself rather than be an obstacle
what other approaches do you take in
your work life or personal life to
maintain positivity or use positivity I
consider being in a good mood the most
important part of my creative process so
right or wrong I don't i personally
don't get up early unless i'm awake
early if on the war i have somewhere to
be
i know i've read the book we talked
about daily rituals which I love yeah I
made some current great book I'm
demoralized by how many great people
start their day very early were you were
you also I tell you in a bed were you
encourage you to demoralize by how many
of them were drug addicts that was but
you know this Starbucks this venti
Starbucks in front of me like who's to
say that doesn't have the same
stimulation they used back then so you
know if I try to go to bed early and
wake up early but if I need to sleep
late or take a walk in the morning or
whatever I find that being in a good
mood
for creative work is is worth the hours
that takes to get in good mood so often
when I was writing my books I would you
know someone would check in send me a
text at like 11:30 like how are you
doing you know what's it what's up and
I'd say powering up I just feel you know
the first few hours are just getting
into a good mood until I think alright
alright you know I I have an idea I'm
excited about or I have so much
self-loathing and caffeine that I'm like
gotta do something the self-loathing
plus caffeine is a hell of a thing I
what if one of my friends Kelly Starrett
who's a very well-known athletic trainer
calls a cup of fear so you take the
self-loathing and then you yeah drink a
cup of fear I'll tell you my number one
while we're on this number one creative
productivity advice to anyone in I mean
anyone if it works for you I carry
around a notebook and if I don't have a
little notebook I have my phone you know
but I really divide my creative work
into two distinct phases which is the
idea phase and the execution phase and I
do not let either interrupt the other or
yeah yeah that's the best way to say it
so if I'm taking a walk or I'm having a
drink with a friend and just some funny
idea comes up something that makes me
smile or or some other impulse I write
it down and I never judge well what
would you do with this idea or how would
you end that joke never I just have this
notebook I feel like the richest man in
the world in terms of ideas just fill it
up feel great always never question it
then on a separate day a sit down
you know 9:00 or 10:00 a.m. with a big
cup of coffee at my desk go through the
notebook and I do my best with every
idea in the book so I never am
intimidated when you're best you're
developing yeah each one on a separate
piece of paper or something like that
yeah yeah on my computer usually or
continue an idea on the computer that I
left off the previous day but you know
but first I'll check my notebook I have
any ideas for solutions or whatever so
the idea to me everything is idea and
execution and if you separate idea and
execution you don't put too much
pressure
on either of them I was reading an
article by Isaac Asimov bounce
creativity in groups versus solo
creativity and very similar conclusion
that he kept to him just keeping them
separate now when you do you have a
particular type of notebook particular
type of yeah you like yeah I use the
moleskin cat here as I say I've no idea
that's item cah ier
you can go on Amazon and buy these three
packs so they're much thinner than the
typical moleskin notebook so you can
really you can keep it in your pocket
easier and you finish them so you feel
more production you feel them up in a
couple and then I have a huge box of
them but I use that and I use the
uniball vision pen and generally how do
you do you date them how do you keep
track of what do i order different
colors and mix up the colors that I
order and then I buy on Amazon these
huge batches of stickers shape stickers
the teachers use to put on you know
reports and stuff like stars and circles
and blue rectangles and stuff and every
time I start a new notebook I read my
phone number in the first page in case
it didn't yep and then I put a sticker
in the top left corner of the book that
lets me know what which one I'm on
currently and then I have a yellow I'm
sorry I have a red box for I have a
white box for untranscribed notebooks
because then I transcribe the mine
computer and a red box for transcribed
notebooks and I don't date them and I
always tell myself I should date them
this is crazy because when I go through
the white box you know I'm jumping
around six months ago four months ago
you know I'm not going in order but I
guess just I'm not gonna question it cuz
something about the creative process I
just don't want to date them I just
don't know interesting what I mean maybe
that would create some bias against
older material I mean for the same
reason that I take dates on my blog
posts and I move to them from the top
two as a small italicized line at the
bottom and my traffic jump out like 20
30% because people no longer - to alter
material that's very interesting that's
I on the list up - we we keep an eye on
what and we're gonna talk a lot about
list not not trying to rush it you know
we're gonna get there the yeah I love
the red box and white box when you
develop these or do your best with them
as you said on the computer are you
doing this in a particular app or
program or is it limited to whatever
your current focuses say a book or a
screenplay or film I use Microsoft Word
um same reason my dad used word star
it's just what I learned it got in the
habit of and I use final draft for
screenplays because everyone does I
would like I know there's other software
out there I would like something that
kind of combines the two because often I
would like to kind of write a paragraph
and then kind of throw in dialogue
easily but uh I it's not worth it to me
to investigate and switch yeah there's
there's tool that I've used for my last
few books that I found extremely helpful
it's not as it's not as focused on
screen writing as say final draft
although people do use it for that
called Scrivener unfavorite yeah I've
used it for my last two books I found
extremely helpful for that format I
think it's mostly used by playwrights I
want to say but there are screenwriters
use it when you see you like grass I was
gonna mention who invented Firefox yeah
he's an investor in the list app and
I've been trying to get him for years to
develop with me like a screenplay
writing sniper because he's actually a
terrific writer and he wrote the Silicon
Valley spec script that he put on
Twitter which is such a tech way to get
your spec out there but it was it was
great and I think he would be the guy to
crack it because he's the writer and
also the software developer I think he
still in the Bay Area or s he yeah I
need to actually spend some time with he
was very very kind when I think it was
2007 gave me a quote for the 4-hour
workweek and I feel very indebted to him
so he's awesome so if you're hearing
this thank you so much I really owe you
a coffee and container a bottle of wine
and probably more
when you how do you think of yourself I
mean I guess it depends on perhaps what
project you're working on but which of
these many activities and artistic
projects crafts that you've attempted do
you most identify with writer writer
yeah any particular type or is it just
across the board writer probably a
comedy writer to be honest I for two
reasons one is just it's the identity I
come from I think it was Woody Allen who
said if you you know I do these
different things but if you woke me up
and shook me in the middle of the night
and said what what are you I'd say
writer I definitely feel like that
that's a good question I should rephrase
my question I'm gonna walk over the
middle of night and shook you and said
what's your job what would you say you
know I guess the simpler way is what do
you put on your passport or your customs
declaration I always matter but I think
that everything I do is sort of a
version of writing even if I'm acting
I'm sort of writing the way that I think
this character would act do you know
what I mean
of course hum so it were if I have an
idea and I really feel like you know
idea and execution that to me is right
if you were teaching a let's see
Freshman Seminar
at Harvard on comedy writing mmm what
would the what would the curriculum look
like oh great great question
well PJ O'Rourke who was one of the big
national impune editors said that if he
talks write letter C of dunces did he
write that no am i making it up but he
might have written the introduction to
it or something all right
so he said that if he ever taught
English he would assign parodies maybe
cuz that's when you really learn
something that's to parody it so I would
probably assign parodies of literature I
would
oh there any particular parodies that
just sort of whatever you're studying in
your other classes parody that I said
really I think would open you up
I think mischief is just so important in
comedy it's really there's just
something like am I really allowed to
say that you know there
just the cool thing am I really allowed
to hear that I could pontificate I know
a couple things that I I feel I have
discovered about comedy though this is
one is that the perfect first of all the
most important thing is it is sort of a
it's like a physical it's like sex in
that it's about whether the other person
is enjoying it or not or you're enjoying
it you know like you could say do this
and that and then if neither of you has
a good time
you couldn't insist to me like but I had
good sex no you didn't like that I gave
you my best advice like touch your here
and take your time and whisper this like
I could do that but you'll know if it's
a good sex or not these are just tips
like it's a physical reaction that
you're going for so there's that you
know whatever you teach it's like a
you'll you'll feel it you don't feel
that you'll hear it you'll know
so do it a lot and you know probably you
know don't take this class too seriously
one thing I've definitely learned about
comedy I don't know how it applies to
what what maybe it applies to editing
more than just to writing or finding
what's good comedy but I believe that a
good comedy operates the exact same way
a good mystery operates which is the
punchline should be something that we
write in front of your face the whole
time and you never would have put your
finger on it's like the red doorknobs of
the success doorknob yeah exactly
of course he was dead the whole time you
know like how did I not get that that
excitement that elation or like it was
the butler it was the narrator you know
whatever it was that's the best comedy
when someone points out something you're
like oh my god that was so obvious I
never would got another thing is that
observation observations are really the
currency of comedy anything you do if
you observe something that touches a
chord with somebody and that has not
been expressed right you can turn that
into a movie you can turn that into a
plot you can turn that into a one-liner
but anytime you observe something that
that a good new observation that's what
fuels 99
comedy and the other 1% is just people
falling down or whatever and it's are
there any particular comics or comedy
writers who are very good in your mind
at the red doorknob effect so hey hit me
with punchlines that are have kind of
been there all along huh but they they
do a good well as these I'm sorry has a
bit about marriage that I find brilliant
I think it was one or two specials ago
enough flex where he's like if we
invented marriage now if you if no one
had heard of marriage and you proposed
it to a girl you would freak her out
beyond belief you know I want a vow that
will never like ever sleep with anyone
else and I want like rings and our
fingers to symbolize it and I want a
priest to be there when everyone we've
ever met and there'll be a ceremony will
be in the newspaper you know that is so
funny to me because it's completely true
never would have noticed it louis c.k is
brilliant at pointing the stuff out
saying things that is kind of how you
felt but he never would have thought of
it but even you know an an abstract
one-liner comic like Zach Galifianakis
who I tried to see whenever I could when
I moved to LA you know even those are
like right that phrase could mean that
or wide sure even that is an observation
even that's true about language that's
sure right like 24-hour banking who has
time for that Stephen right yeah right
approach is really really good as that
is now that I'm getting sort of a finer
feel for forty meant is this was a lot I
suppose
perhaps the majority of really good
stand-up comics are good at this I don't
know but why I'm applying Demetri Martin
yeah yeah Demetri Martin right I'm
really good at the wordplay so you
mentioned you mentioned movies we've
mentioned list app a few times and I
feel like we should dig into that
because my next question would be
related to and maybe by means of example
we can get into list app the I was going
to ask you for screenwriters what would
your curriculum look like and you put up
a list recently and
and maybe you can explain the the app as
well but you put up a list of some of
your favorite movies so you had
adaptation you had naked gunned down
towards the bottom and I don't know the
top five though yeah it's a tough I was
adaptation Ferris Bueller's Day Off Pulp
Fiction Casablanca The Naked Gun
this is just personal what right you
know just if I were really gonna die
tomorrow and they said you could play a
couple I'm not trying to press anybody
like you know it's just it's not film
history it's just me now the with those
films correspond to the five screenplays
you would suggest people read if you
were signing them yeah probably probably
the writing is front and center for all
of them now adaptation is brilliant
because it breaks all the rules and
comments on all the rules so maybe I
wouldn't teach that first that sort of
play also if anybody says I want to be a
writer at least for me yeah I would say
watch that movie yeah talk you out of it
yeah I could really use a doughnut god
I'm so hungry you know I guess all of
these movies break the form and maybe
that's why you know Casablanca probably
I don't know enough about film history
but it probably broke the form now it is
the form so maybe I would you know but
there are weird things in that pop
fiction obviously completely breaks a
form chronologically Ferris Bueller he
narrates the movie to camera the Naked
Gun is just they'll do anything for a
laugh you know I guess that's kind of
formal in a way adaptation you know
completely commenting on itself so yeah
maybe I think one lesson in all of that
is you know it's not about the rules
it's about you in the audience anything
that you do so this is maybe adalah feel
a little bit do you like have you seen
memento yeah did you enjoy that movie I
thought was okay so what I saw it I
really enjoyed it but that a lot of
people hold that up as an example of a
movie that broke the rules where it
didn't work like it or it was it was
trying too hard to break the rules or
something
like I think it's a great if I were him
if I were Nolan I would and that was my
first big movie I'd be very proud that I
got everyone's attention it's extremely
clever as an idea and if that's enough
to give you pleasure watching it or if
that's enough to get your attention to
watch it and then you got pleasure
watching I agree that premise is
fantastically clever
I just wasn't personally especially
moved watching the story and I you know
he's so big it won't matter if I
criticize him but I have a real problem
with the the Chris Nolan worship in
cinema I think I would that's a
screenplay that's a writer I would never
teach if I were teaching screenwriting
Weissach says the guy who's never
written a screenplay because a movie
should be a pleasurable experience that
is my one sentence answer and I find his
movies cold and formal and I find his
demeanor as a public director called
informal and pleased I make this a
headline this is all the way here I can
see yeah everyone has opinions but um
yeah I find his movies completely
unpleasurable scoots off to TMZ and I
feel that the formality has conned
people into reverence when in fact no
one was smiling in any of these Batman
movies that everyone gave such a claim
to and no one was smiling at inception
and no one understood interstellar I am
a well-educated guy I have a real
interest in science I write screen
stories for a living and I could not
follow this so who is following this you
know a movie should be entertaining you
and and inviting you in so that's that's
a screenwriter I would not teach got it
how did you get into tech and why tech I
find tech and again this is sort of the
formal rules of anything first of all
Tech is the best field at at being the
first to tell you that there are no
rules it's about what you make and how
people respond to it which I really love
and I you know I think Tech is leading
the way for entertainment and you
realize oh every
about you know very soon on the Apple TV
you'll be able to say the MIDI project
and you won't have any idea what network
it's on it's all about weather Mindy
Kaling full disclosure a good friend of
mine it's all about weather Mindy Kaling
has made a good show gotten the budget
gotten the cast convinced them to do it
that's a big deal and made it well
that's a very big deal and gotten enough
publicity for it that you are curious
about it but that's it and there has
been a lot of [ __ ] in terms of what
night is it on and what's the
competition like and how is it you know
and who picked it up and why and who
funded it and how much do they get and
is it gonna make syndication and that
noise has nothing to do with the product
and the audience and I think the tech is
leading the way and removing that and I
think tech is really I the reason I've
always been drawn to it and always
pitched every idea I ever had and texted
my friends in tech it's because it
seemed like a utopian version of you
have an idea and you see if it's a good
idea you know just like with stand-up
just like with writing scenes for the
office I think this is a great idea but
I won't know until it goes to the set
and it succeeds or fails or I bring it
onstage and no one laughs or everyone
does laughs that to me is the biggest
pleasure is having an idea and if and
seeing if you're right and so tech seem
to me you could have a huge idea and and
it could be right whereas in other
fields a huge idea you need to be at a
huge scale to even try it out so that's
why I always had like you know I that's
why I met Blake Ross because in two
thousand six or seven you know I had a
friend Charlie Cheever who worked at
Facebook sure and I said can I see
Facebook you know can I have a tour so
and I would cultivate these friendships
and these guys to me that was I think
what a lot of people looked at show
business
and in the world I was in and thought
that's so creative I would look at this
world and think wow you can have an idea
and then if it works it works that's
that's so beautiful the other is a and
of course like everything it turns out
to be way more complicated yeah but I
think
less complicated than other fields and
less and less complicated from the
standpoint of testing ideas right
because you have cheaper and cheaper
rentable infrastructure whether it's
Amazon Web Services or otherwise you
have a global talent market where you
might as people remotely or locally or
in some distributed fashion like
automatic which I advise and the guys
who do WordPress common one I mean they
have 400 plus people who are all
distributed and then you have the
Kickstarter's and other means of funding
that weren't available five ten years
ago so if you had an idea for a store 20
years ago
that's you really put your whole life
your on hold to pursue that a compromise
of a compromise of that idea for a store
yeah and now you can you can make that
sort you can do in an afternoon and then
let's see see how it goes
so can you describe then what it is that
you're working on right now so this is
uh I've tried to get you on and I know
we'll get you on when we have Android
this is the list app and it's as simple
as it sounds it's LST is our domain so
eventually when we have web we'll
probably just want to be known as list
but it's it's really that simple and we
aim to be that universal just to place
for lists socially so that my original
idea was we all have these lists in our
phones in our notebooks in our minds of
what a good restaurants in LA etcetera I
wish I could see those lists on the
phones or whatever of the people I care
about or occasionally a celebrity or a
publication that I would turn to for
this type of thing and I wanted a place
it seemed so simple to me why hasn't it
been done I thought a place where you
could put these lists and everyone would
put them and then you could search them
and read them and that is essentially
what we built so in this case yeah like
I think I think I'm right you know I'm
not saying I'm a genius or anything at
all I I it seemed like this was
something worth testing and if you do it
right and someone shows you an idea and
you say oh not that but yes that and
like anything else the most important
thing is is who you partner with and so
I knew I didn't know this
and I I hired a company to make
screenshots because everyone I pitched
this to treated me the way I would treat
them if a tech person pitched me a good
idea for a TV show I'd say that sounds
like a good idea I don't think you
understand what it takes to do you have
a director do you have funding do you
have a cast do you know how to do a
rewrite you know no no I mean just an
idea shouldn't someone make you know so
that's how they treated me and I thought
well I need to show that I'm serious and
that it would be good so I asked friend
after friend II know anyone who could
make mock-ups for me so I hired this
great company called two toasters
- yeah and apparently was named after
coincidentally an office reference where
he ends up with two toasters because he
bought one for Phyllis's wedding but I
didn't know that when I didn't even
remember the reference when I met them
so I drew up I'm not a good artist but I
drew very simple you know again I'm this
is not anything innovative I drew up
what a list would look like very similar
to Twitter to Instagram to tumblr you
know a very you know vertical feed of
lists and how you'd search for them and
how you'd add a suggestion to someone
else's and how you'd compose and ask can
you make sort of a nice mock-up of each
of these main screens so they I paid
them to make them and then I would walk
around away tell people the idea and
then saying that sounds good I'd show
them and they would try to tap and they
couldn't because it was just a mock-up
and that that's how I knew okay they
want to be using this I showed them that
I'm serious they they know what it feels
like to want to see the next screen and
I showed then I went to then the guy to
toasters Simon said I host a tech
breakfast in New York once a month I was
gonna be in town for that tech breakfast
so I went to it talked to everyone
I'd say about 49% of the people were way
too nice to me because I was a celebrity
about 49% of the people were way too
hard on me because I was a celebrity and
what am I doing here
then there was like one guy who took me
seriously who met me at my level and
said I liked it for these reasons I
think these are my concerns and you know
and his name was Matt Witt hilar and he
was a VC at flybridge which is not
doesn't do this kind of thing generally
but he was interested
so I asked if I could have lunch with
him I almost cancelled I was hungover
I'm like what am i doing I I'm here I
like to do press for a TV show and why
am i pursuing this crazy tech thing I
like everyone wants to do a start-up I
almost canceled but I didn't I show up
to meet him and he says um he says I
know the co-founder for you I don't
think you can get him but it's worth a
try I've been trying to convince this
guy to leave his job forever but I think
he might like this because he's done
stuff like this before his name was dev
clarity he ran product at fab he
previously worked for a sort of a map
based travel startup and the original
idea for this was travel lists of course
would be big so I said I'm let's let me
try it was leaving the next day an email
dev had dinner with them at the Ace
Hotel in New York the Breslin and we sat
down a single daddy food yeah right away
I was like I'm doing that
I'm doing with this guy I'm not doing it
you know he we were the exact same watch
and IWC pilot so like a nice simple
watch with great design great classic
design
we ordered a bullet bourbon each of us
so we have the same taste you know and
just like Matt would hilar he was hard
on the idea and respected the idea
asking all the right questions and and
he and he could talk and he his wife was
a was a television writer and he was
interested in what I was interested in
and he was telling Lee he was a Parks
and Recreation fan but not an office fan
he he liked the kinds of things I liked
but he was not impressed by me my
celebrity he heard I was somebody but
you know he didn't care he cared about
Ron Swanson so you know he was like
Jason it was the perfect match and he
said Lina let me think about it let me
think about it and then his wife kept
getting up for jobs in Halle grosses
fantastic writer I think she's a
fantastic writer fantastic talker and
thinker and she's on great shows so I
assumed she's great
so she kept getting more and more
attention in LA and then she was up for
this huge writing job in LA on an HBO
show and no one was rooting for that job
harder than me I'm praying that Halle
gets hired because I know if Deb moves
to LA I'm sure
do this and sure enough she got the job
and he finally committed to doing this
and you know he's really been leading
sort of the-- the overall you know why i
think this is so good is because of deaf
i have a lot to do with the community i
obviously have a lot to do with the the
conception and I argue for all my tastes
all the time but 90 plus percent of the
time dev has already arrived there and
and added more things that I should have
thought of what are some of the more
popular lists that have popped up well I
can look at the trending lists right now
and I'll mention one to people yeah and
and just because I found this actually
very very cool and helpful which was a
list which you put on Twitter or
retweeted I think it was Cheryl Strayed
and writer Wilde which was made into a
movie and she put out a list of writing
prompts so assignments or I think there
were some more sentences or questions
that you could use for writing exercises
and what is your Twitter handle at BJ
Novak so very simple happy Jay Novak so
download the app and also follow BJ on
Twitter because he highlights also quite
a few different lists but that list in
and of itself that was great and she
also did a list that was very moving
which is objects found in my mother's
car at the moment of her death or the
time of her death you know just like a
pen
you know lipstick could tickets to this
play I don't remember exactly what it
was it was but I remember being just so
stunned by the simplicity of of that
power and list form and you know there's
a lot of writers on it so that you know
there's a literary thing but I'm looking
here you know it's a mix of publications
doing lists celebrities doing lists and
of course mostly just regular folks but
trending right now the Washington Post
made a list of the things Donald Trump
has called on America to boycott he's
called for a lot of boycotts over the
years it's very interesting including
the company that makes his clothing fine
which he didn't realize
Vox made a list what NASA picked to
explain our world to aliens so what they
put on Voyager 1 and 2 just you know
coolest a girl named Jenna Martin I know
I made a list favorite Howard Stern
interviews and that's an open list so
you can make a suggestion on that list
and if she likes it she double taps it
what is what are the top what are the
top on the the Howard Stern Howard Stern
interviews Lady Gaga Bill Hader Billy
Joel which was a great one I heard that
one Jonah Hill Jerry Seinfeld great
interviewer James Taylor I did not know
that although I've seen him be dark and
funny Chris Martin apparently so you
know some of them are very helpful
recommendations a lot of books lists and
some of them are very funny no it's
December correct me if I have faulty
memory here but ever we were chatting on
the phone a few months ago yeah
was it Lena Dunham who had dead people
I'd have sex with my that up and I'm
looking right now Anthony Bourdain made
one that I thought was really follow
this was was that for spy novels three
written by spies as well yeah I did that
he's big reader and writer obviously his
most recent one is called Hotel [ __ ]
that's me and you know it's it's very
much his writing style but it's the
hotels that he will stay he will make an
excuse to go to that town if he can say
in the following hotels including one in
port-au-prince Katie Chateau Marmont
here in LA the Raliegh in Miami
so his lists are great needs anything in
New York let me see what his New York
choice is headed to New York surely the
meal tray there's a lot of lists of like
New York hotels but I you know there's
also a list of if you ever stay at the
Bowery which is my favorite hotel there
Barry's great um there's two people at
least have made lists of the best rooms
at the Bowery 14:03 has this and 1401
has though that's very useful I are
useful I decided to save the barrier
they were sold out for this upcoming
trip so it's very useful and also you
know very creative and there's great
people behind it for someone who
downloads the app what would you suggest
to to get them
a very good taste of the types of
content what we suggest they do I would
suggest just it's a very quick sign of
flow just sign up and there's a
recommended follow menu and you can its
they'll take you to that screen
automatically but one of the things you
can do is you can hit follow all it's
our top like hundred diverse accounts so
I'll read them right now not all one
hundred but you know the first batch
lena dunham mindy kaling the New York
Times Jimmy Fallon the onion Anthony
Bourdain The New Yorker CNN Andy Cohen
vogue snoop Cheryl Strayed Rachael Ray
you know people not everyone's John
Mayer wired TED Talks not everyone's
gonna you know like all of these but
then just unfollow because it will give
you a real you know assortment and
there's a lot of you know civilians on
there to just people that are like
making you know crazy personal or advice
lists and so it's a real I would just
say sign up hit recommended hit follow
all recommended and just see what you
like very cool do you have as we have a
plane zooming overhead did a little bit
more time for some rapid-fire quest a
little bit successful when you hear the
word successful who's the first person
who comes to mind and why Shakespeare
why because he made things that were
both moving and permanent and and
popular what was your oh three things
how far I am from that what what was
your thesis on do you write a senior
thesis well you did your homework yeah I
did one on mine was on it's very
specific in the films of Hamlet how they
treat the line to be or not to be
because that line already has a lot of
mystery within the play exactly what it
means but then you add all the culture
like if you pay to see a movie of Hamlet
like you're waiting for it to be or not
to be the whole time so how do the
cultural expectations affect the
interpretation of that line got it
bard I mean it's a lot of people who
make me want to cry into a pillow be as
it as a writer who's trying to improve
that's that's certainly wake up at the
top yes what book or books do you give
most often as gifts there's a book
called the Oxford book of aphorisms
which I love it's just the most well
edited like brilliant one-liners from
history um and you can just you can
spend like hours on a page it's just
where you can just flip through it I
give that one a lot
the Oxford I'm gonna give daily rituals
that book we mentioned a lot - is anyone
who's creative or ambitious you take so
much solace and seeing all the different
processes people just do you know what
does Charles Dickens do every day what
did he do every day what Darwin do every
day what Steve Jobs do every day you
know it's just so reassuring to see like
everyone's got their own system and it
it it also is very reassuring to see how
dysfunctional so many of them are yes
depressing depressing in some cases
great book I actually produce the audio
book for people who want to try the
audio if you could change one thing
about yourself what would it be
I'd love to be great-looking thank you
but you know I look at James Franco and
he doesn't look at his brother I mean
they're like no I'm saying it's a
handsome film and if I could have
whatever I wanted yeah I I could lie and
say oh I'd learn to be better at empathy
no I'd be like [ __ ] awesome looking
and you know then I would like you know
if you're James Franco you can do
anything on paper like well it's pretty
interesting and I wish I had that extra
level no I appreciate the awesome this
is good do you have any bad habits that
you're currently working on yeah of
course I I shone out any conversation of
not holding a microphone I out easily I
just love daydreaming and I think it is
it's so indulgent in a good way to the
creative process but then you get used
to that indulgence when someone else
deserves your attention so I try to be
better at that how do you go about
trying to be come better if then it's
just a conscious decision not to zone
out good question I don't have a process
yet I'm just always I do the same thing
so if you come up with anything please
let me know words or phrases that you
overuse pretty that's my one today oh I
hate it I started trying to fix it by
saying do you use it as an adverb or an
adjective how to use an adverb see I use
it as magic oh okay but I don't mind
using it okay yeah I say oh that's
pretty interesting
oh that's print is producing I tried to
fix it at one point by forcing myself to
say [ __ ] after it says that's pretty
[ __ ] interesting yeah that's [ __ ]
smart and eventually it short-circuited
for a while it's definitely I over used
like which is so embarrassing because
it's not a very masculine word to
overuse but I do like as a verb or like
Isis and I don't even know what it is
it's a stutter really like I see but do
you have anything in writing long form
let's say in a book one of mine is for
instance like that having been said or
so sure I overwrite a lot and I need to
pare it down
God is just a revision phrase but no no
I mean I just I do stuff like that
because it's it sounds I don't know it
kind of it gives extra elegance to a
stupid idea and then I need to go down
and be like you know what put somebody
in a suit yeah it's something I learned
on the office too if you're if a scene
should be two pages and it's four pages
it's a bad scene it's just you because
you keep writing when you haven't hit it
so if it's a great scene you know it
might just be a two line exchange I love
you I don't love you like whoa that's a
scene but if if the scene is like so I
was thinking the other day my feeling
you know like that's not a scene oh it's
not work yeah so if you overwrite it's
often a sign that that you have not hit
it and you're still looking for it what
what is the best
purchase that you've made in recent
memory for less than $100 an ice cube
tray that has giant ice cubes in it any
time I'm at a bar and they have like a
big ice cube I feel like oh what this
should cost like a hundred dollars this
is so nice and then I thought well wait
the the rubber ice cube tray shouldn't
be any more expensive it's just a
different shaped mold so I go on Amazon
and I'm sure enough Tibble oh I think is
the company you know for like seven
dollars it's six huge ice cubes and if
anyone comes over and I make them a
drink they have one huge ice cube in
their glass and it's like I have a fancy
bar give me favorite documentaries you
know what do you mind if I look at the
list app I don't mind if you look at the
list of documentaries on the list tab I
love documentaries and I'll throw out
justify sometime I'll throw one out well
I loved man on wire when it came okay or
uniquely put together and the same team
made a documentary subsequent to that
called project NIM which was about a
chimpanzee that this was in the 70s
effectively raised as a human child to
see if NIM in this case could I think it
was gnome known in Chomsky or chimpsky
they called him in any case could
acquire language and just a fascinating
documentary on human thought human
interaction with this chimp and so on on
my list catfish it's a cliche but
catfish is a brilliant documents it's
really its generation-defining and it's
just become a term but it earned to that
term brilliant movie to be in to have is
on my list a beautiful a beautiful
simple film about a one-room schoolhouse
in France and just what happens over the
course of year there's really little
story but but it really holds your
attention and gives you a spirit of a
place and if I choose one more oh you
know it's a really cool one it's called
the overnighters and it's about the oil
fields in North Dakota came out a couple
years ago on this path
stur who has a church there hmm the back
and oil fields which is like probably
bigger than the gold rush and the 1800s
and just like now that you can frack
there's so much oil in North Dakota that
a whole like culture like you you can
rent like a garage in North Dakota for
like two hundred fifty thousand dollars
you know it's just there's so much money
there in such a rush to be close to it
and that's a really interesting the
overnighters so i usually ask about
morning routines but i want to ask about
and and you can feel free to answer that
but i'm so curious to dig a little bit
into your powering up yeah how would you
power up to kind of get into the zone I
have a venti pike place coffee from
Starbucks I find that what how is it
made just black
yep black I find that brewing my own
coffee at home is so unpredictable it's
like getting artisanal tile and all I
want to know what my dose is you know
like you wouldn't be like oh I made some
tylenol for no give me two Tylenol so I
want a standard dose of caffeine what
your standard yeah like loading does
okay got it so I have a venti from
Starbucks now when you have it you mean
you purchase or do you just down the
thing like a shot of tequila I either
drive to the Starbucks no I it takes an
hour because I'm I will sometimes read
the paper the Wall Street Journal or the
recently The Wall Street Journal which I
find really good especially on weekends
but or the New York Times is my favorite
and I often read that usually be that
online and you know just emails and I
turn on music I usually listen to the
Morning Becomes eclectic on kcrw
Morning Becomes a clock yeah it's this
great show from 9:00 to 12:00 every
weekday commercial-free like just cool
new music I also have a list on my on
the app of music that I work too so and
they have a 24 hour station do you burn
other ones that you can pull from memory
that yeah yeah
I will often do Pandora of early blues
early is good too just so yeah I listen
to music or Sirius XM 35 is like indie
music that I like so you just listen to
me it's just
being in a good mood I slowly drink that
Starbucks I sometimes take a walk around
Runyon Canyon or my neighborhood you
know text email if there's a book I'm
kind of reading a read a couple chapters
and then eventually I'm just like all
right like either I'm excited by an idea
or I'm it's like 3:30 and I'm like this
powering up turned into lunch turned
into a workout you know and I'm like god
dammit I cleared out my whole day and
it's three [ __ ] thirty and I haven't
written anything you know then I just
start looking at my files and then I
finally get going
so yeah the powerup can have a happy or
sad ending do you is there a particular
time of day that you find you you tend
to do your best writing um for me it's
always been super late night I don't
know why that is for CSS for note-taking
for interviewing I can do that whenever
but for synthesis have always been kind
of a 10:00 p.m. to 5:00 and cutting I
for whatever reason um it's hard for me
to get myself to work later in the day
so probably my most productive time is
like 11:00 to 2:00 but um that you know
the creative ideas can come any time I
never know when those are coming let's
see here
if people wanted to watch besides the
office one or two TV shows for good
comedy writing any particular
recommendations I love the show right
now called the grinder with Rob Lowe at
Fred Savage that's very very good
writing season four of mr. show is
brilliant sketch writing could you
explain me my sky I apologize my sketch
like SNL like you know it's got an
Isetta yeah I'd say yeah those are those
are pretty great ones cool just a few
more questions yeah what historical
figure you must identify with Oh in my
hopes Ben Franklin because he started in
comedy and then I make a joke about this
in my stand-up act like he really took
it
oh the next level I mean he wrote Poor
Richard's Almanack and he was known as a
comedy writer and then he ended up you
know discovering electricity and having
his face on money like that is really
any remained like a witty guy so my hope
is that I could do some shadow where I
can have ambitious positive spirited
ideas but it won't be like oh now like
he lost a sense of humor like Ben
Franklin always had a sense of humor and
it wasn't a shame to like like
experiment with you know a lightning you
know yeah like that that's really cool
but I even in my most egotistical I
don't actually identify with him he's
just like you know if I'm supposed to
show up yeah aspirational figure so
probably someone more you yeah someone I
don't know like funny and dark and like
for someone I'm recognizing that no path
is quite the same for people certainly
that that I've met in entertainment or
comedy or whatnot from going from school
to the industry of if we could call it
one industry of entertainment let's just
say you had a promising high school
senior yeah who is a gifted writer and
they think they want to be in comedy
writing what advice would you give them
a bunch of things one piece of advice
that I stand by that I've given to a
bunch of people is there's really to
think of it as two things you need to
get people's attention and you need to
be able to back it up so this is
especially forgetting I feel like most
people who want to get into comedy what
they want to do these days is get a
staff job on a TV comedy show so to do
that you need think like the person
hiring you
you're gonna want if you were given your
own show you'd panic this is my one big
shot it's gotta be hilarious you hire
your most loyal funniest friends first
then you'd ask around you know who
worked on you know my favorite Josie who
is the best best best person you know
and those names would come to you
through an agent or something and then
you'd like anyone that you saw or heard
or you were at a stand-up show and this
guy was hilarious or someone sent you
this internet video or you know you just
don't know or you'd ask around and
someone would send you something so the
first thing is get their attention that
means could mean be friends with
somebody or have collaborated with
somebody another thing is you might want
to make something I don't for me it was
stand-up but I don't know what it is for
anyone else it could be
probably some internet video it'd feel
like that's the best way to you can be
completely wild and get seen but you
know make something truly great that
could be anything absolutely anything
then once you have someone's attention
they're gonna want to be sure that
they're not taking a crazy bet on some
kid who made some funny video who then
gets in the writers room and doesn't
know what to do so that generally means
have a spec script which is a
speculative script that could be for a
TV show so you write an episode of The
Office or The Simpsons or whatever just
to show that if you were on that stuff
you'd be able to know the voices you
know how to format it you'd know how to
craft the story you can write hard jokes
so have you know a spec script and
probably take you a few to get a really
good one
but back it up and get their attention
now that's for anyone starting out I
don't know if I'd advise a high school
senior to go right into TV writing so
this device is probably more for someone
who just graduated college or someone
whatever stage of life they're just
ready to start this so you know if if
you're really gonna go to college I'd
say you know stay funny be around funny
people come up with funny ideas make
your friends laugh um be mischievous
yeah be mischievous now you are living
this up 33:6
what advice would you give your 30 year
old self and and where were you what
were you doing at 30 at 30 I was on the
office I wish I had told myself on the
office and this
might be specific to me the whole time I
was in the office I thought well this is
my best shot at whatever I'd ever want
to do so I better not waste a second I
better write a screenplay I better you
know make a avant-garde film I better
get cast in something I better do my big
thing while I'm still in the office
because I don't want to be that guy who
used to be on the office so but I didn't
have time to jobs on the office either
one of them takes up you should take up
your focus now you it's a 1-point you're
three right I mean me was writer
producer actor well producer tends to
just be high-level writer God so I take
that that was the same job but you know
it's important it means the writing is
really for the whole show is part of
your responsibility so I wish I could
tell and now people ask me did you what
was it like when the office was it's so
much fun were you laughing all the time
yeah but I have to admit that's buried
under I was so anxious and always trying
to write some extra thing on the side
that I never finished and never a time
for and I really didn't just enjoy this
incredible once-in-a-lifetime thing and
you know as soon as the office ended I
was talented enough to write a book and
I'm proud of the book and I made the app
and I worked really hard and I was able
to pull it off like you know if you can
do it you can do it it's you're not
really on someone else's schedule ever
and you know I also tell people all the
time like if Will Smith isn't in a movie
for three years you're not walking
around saying where's Will Smith no
one's paying attention to anybody else
at all you think everyone is but they're
not so we'll take as long as you want if
you're talented it's not really you know
you'll you'll get their attention again
if you have reason to and so I do wish I
had told myself back then like this is
this is very very special like own it be
and enjoy it instead of you know being
so nervous and you know all for nothing
none of the things I tried to do on the
side of the office ever got anywhere
because I just didn't have time I think
that's good advice for a lot of people
in a lot of places that was the advice
also that Stephen King gave to Neil game
one of my favorite fishing writers was
the advice as well he said enjoy it
because Neal was sitting at I think it
was a book signing for Sandman which was
just this incredible canon of work that
redefined what was possible in sort of
the graphic novel genre yeah I know if
that was too incredible and he's used
that of course as a stepping stone to
write novels and and that were have been
turned into movies and so on but he was
sitting there with this huge line of
people as I remember it and he said
enjoy this and that's my laptop sliding
but he didn't he had a lot of trouble
enjoying it yeah and I think that's a
constant battle well I don't want to
take up any more of your time this has
been a blast it's getting so great it's
getting dark and probably time for some
food where can people find you and what
you're up to online where the best
places to have to go hide you know I
think the best place is the list up
because that's where I am so I would say
download the list app on the App Store
or it'll be on Android and web soon and
that's just three words they'll list app
or go to LST and my profile there is all
my favorites and ideas and thoughts on
this and that I'm also on Twitter
yeah they got BJ Novak happy genomic
that's me analyst up - cool well this
has been great fun maybe we'll do around
to sometime and thanks so much again
really [ __ ] it's so cool and to
everybody listening you can find the
show notes links to all the books shows
apps etc that were mentioned at 4-hour
workweek comm forward slash podcast or
you can just go to 4-hour workweek comm
and click on podcast has show notes for
this episode in every other episode and
as always until next time thank you for
listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealth front as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first 15,000 which is managed for free
if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a use
and have them on the podcast but I've
been so impressed by wealthfront that
I've invested a significant amount of my
own money at least for me in the team
and the company itself so I am an
investor and hope to soon use it as a
client now back to the recommendation as
a Tim Ferriss show listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast free there's
no downside that I can think of now I do
have to read a mandatory disclaimer
wealthfront Inc is an SEC registered
investment advisor investing in
securities involves risks and there is
the possibility of losing money past
performance is no guarantee of future
results please visit wealth front comm
to read their full disclosure so check
it out guys this is one of the hottest
most innovative companies coming out of
Silicon Valley and they're killing it
they've become massively popular just
take a look see what portfolio they
would create for you and you can use
that information however you want
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo
Pro which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a
bunch of my startups already use Vimeo
Pro including wealthfront who uses it to
explain how wealthfront works TaskRabbit
uses it to tell their company's story
and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers Airbnb
Etsy etc why do they use it well Vimeo
Pro provides enterprise level video
hosting for a fraction of the usual cost
features include gorgeous high quality
playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week unlimited
plays and views and a fully customizable
video player which can include your logo
custom outro etc you also get VIP
support and you get all of this for just
$1.99 per year that's $17 a month with
no complicated bandwidth calculations or
hidden fees and you can try it risk-free
for 30 days so check it out Vimeo comm
forward slash business that's bi m EO
com forward slash business and use promo
code Tim to get 25% off that's a special
discount just for you guys so check it
out Vimeo com forward slash business
promo code Tim and until next time thank
you for listening